okay well if there's anything i can do
good bloody surgery you know bloody
surgeries make me feel better
[Music]
one two three four ah follow me
if sandra oh was your person on grey's
anatomy and the news that the show would
be renewed for an 18th season
sparked hope that the actress would
return as christina yang
you might want to stop watching somebody
say
me the actress once again shut down
rumors of a possible return to the hit
abc medical drama
noting on the los angeles times podcast
asian enough
that she has moved on i left that show
my god
seven years ago almost so i in my mind
it's
it's gone but for a lot of people it's
still very much alive
and while i understand and i love it i
have moved on
i love it though and you know and this
is also why i really appreciate the show
is that i still get asked this oh played
christina yang for the first
10 seasons of grey's anatomy before
announcing her departure in 2013.
her performance earned her a golden
globe as well as
five emmy award nominations now if
you're really mourning o's performance
on the show
we have a few other projects you might
want to check out
once i tell you about them your lives
are in danger
don't tell us they're called the 12. oh
has captivated audiences in killing eve
as mi5 security officer eve who's
obsessed
with the talented assassin villanelle so
much so that sandra has won
four best actress awards for her
performance in the series
admit it if you wish i was here while
o's performances and greys were
legendary her work in killing eve makes
it seem like this was the role she was
born to play
i'm 47 now and i just feel come on look
at this
it's great it's great and i think
that i'm able to uh
i don't know just take it all in in
in a way that i i don't think i could
have
seven years ago maybe seven years ago i
need to be better
after everything he's done how can i
live up to all that you need to decide
what kind of hero you
want to be sandra most recently voiced
debbie grayson in robert kirkman's
animated superhero series
invincible oh has actually been a part
of multiple animated films
voicing rosie ming in the 2016 tiff film
window horses
and starring alongside kelly marie tran
and aquafina
in raya and the last dragon which made
history as the first
disney film that featured a southeast
asian disney heroine
our lands have been at war for as long
as we can remember
our people never see eye to eye
the actress also voiced the stepmother
of a girl named fei-fei
grieving the loss of her mother in over
the moon and when i spoke with sandra
about the film last year
she told me about her own reaching for
the moon moment
i know i wanted to reach people yeah do
you know how
to reach people that's all i know i knew
i wanted to do i wanted to connect to
people
you know being a performer it's like
this deep um
it's almost like sense of purpose or or
whatever
you're in this you you're able to feel
a a fundamental kind of energy which is
a connection
um but i and i did not realize that it
would
most actually be in in probably
television because
you know my my relationship with
television has
reached the widest audience possible and
she has done just that
back in 2017 sandra guest starred in
another critically acclaimed television
series
american crime where she played abby
tanaka
a woman who runs a shelter for victims
of domestic abuse
the third season of the series dove into
issues of forced labor
sex trafficking and drug use and gave us
this moment between
sandra and her co-star regina king i am
trying to get people in need
a place to stay and if we dig a little
deeper into the sandra o vault we can't
forget her work in 1998's
last night the princess diaries
alongside anne hathaway and the
legendary julie andrews
the queen is coming and under the tuscan
sun with
diane lane there's hot water in the
toilet bowl this is really bad
well it's not good unless you want to
give your butt a facial